it is time to go back into the world of
virtual reality is stronger than you
we're here back at it again with more
but now it's better back in the day I
had a vibe now now now I have so much
more what are you looking at you looking
at my face you better be looking at my
face what are you looking at
you're good of me huh look at me oh
where did I go there I am now your face
thank you no that's too high oh there
you are
hey there we go now that is something's
what no I'm here no it's me stop be nice
okay you behaving now are you going to
be a good boy you're going to be a good
boy good boy
okay all right good great good great
I'm gonna go into VR which is virtual
reality for those of you don't know and
I am going to explore the wonderful
world of Blade and sorcery everybody
shut up
imagine magic real not real virtual
reality which has real in it so I get
why that's confusing but that's not what
so welcome to the wonderful world of
this guy I ever ignored this one I was
trying out the game it's very fun I was
playing it on a different platform but
now that I got the valve redux
I gotta you think they would have come
up with Wireless by now but the valve
Redux which is very good very cool very
cool it uh I
that's anyway I'm gonna make a new
character just for you guys just for all
of you at home am i recording I'm just
guessing that I am cuz cuz if I'm not
cuz cuz if I'm not I'm gonna be real man
there's a lot of lot of moving parts
here there's a lot of oh okay why is it
oh my god oh my god I can't see I just
trying to live life god oh my god holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] I can't see oh I
can't see be good to me go on there you
want it or you want it
are you one okay there we go now you're
on right and I can push you out and
right I can't see I'm looking through my
nose am I good is anything else why mess
with me huh anything I'm gonna take my
aggression out
on the unsuspecting people in this game
okay
Frick oh hi hello I set up this
character as a as an experiment I didn't
think it'd save it here um but all
things considered I might be okay with
this
so with with this what this is is I'm
making my persona my character in this
game and I am going to embody aha
please stand up look straight and click
calibrate said no I don't think I well I
think the height is just right if I'm
gonna be honest with myself and I always
am this is just right love it okay so
we're gonna play this we're gonna we're
gonna wait no no let me no no no okay
wait wait oh oh no no yeah oh I got this
oh yes hi hey how are you hey how's it
going yeah that's me that's my height oh
hey how are you doing oh hey I'm
crouching hey how are you hey listen I
got two tickets to a new show if you
wanted to UM you know go with me oh wait
you're the sexy me who is me look Jesus
Christ uh nice sword
yeah pretty good pretty big right yeah I
thought so anyway I gotta get going I
gotta move on but just wanted to give
you one of these fun give you one of
these
[Music]
oh my goodness oh never mind y'all don't
need to do that I don't need to I can
stand on the ground flat-footed don't
even need to dip it oh I'm so tall yeah
hey Wow nice Brants I'm gonna say nice
pants and a nice prance nice good God
look at my ass I don't really remember
what I was thinking when I was setting
up this character but I like what I see
that's some good stuff right there hey
you stay classy me oh I will oh I will
oh I'm I'm going at it I'm gonna oh
Jesus okay all right not that I need it
I perfectly capable of experiencing
proper hiding you know in my day to day
adventures okay so this this game isn't
yet optimized for the new controllers
but just bear with me for a second I'm
gonna go have a conversation with
okay hey how you doing hey sorry buddy
hey listen listen
okay hey listen if you don't question
what just happened over there I won't
either
ah I'm gonna get myself a brand-new set
of oh yeah
hidden kings okay whatever you want to
call them these are definitely stabs oh
excuse me I have some business to take
care of hey it's me Hey oh you got
something on your brunch what what
I'll get that for you all right bug
landed down there
I need smear to buff out a few scratches
I'm practicing for later not many people
know about this secret technique but I
got this okay all right just about
whacking dummies on their dick it's it's
about where are you are you here
it's about whacking people on their deck
[Music]
so this game what it do good is it do
good combat so I'm gonna show you what
combat do with some good old one-on-one
and what better way to one room what
better way to one-on-one than with us
sweet and save oh yeah oh hey hey okay
well this isn't working as well as I
thought oh no oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
okay my klompers don't even try don't
even try to hey don't even try to get up
don't even try I fight it forward yeah
how about you take some of that and some
of these man my boost is getting the way
of my combat hey no no no you hey yeah
you rethinking your choices aren't you
right now aren't you that's what you get
hey no I wasn't done with you I was not
done with you oh yeah there we go
oh you're dead okay sorry excuse me I
was in the middle of something
just whoopsies Mendte punches okay hey
listen listen listen listen listen
that felt good give me a weapon here
sorry
tall person walking through here there
it is oh oh you think you can run oh no
it's good oh how did you survive that
you I think you did that to yourself
oh yeah I know it wasn't me wasn't one
name oh sorry excuse me I'm sorry you
had something okay so yeah anybody else
I'm slightly crushed I gotta like jump I
really want the height I'm gonna come
for you ha ha death from above
oh it is you know I was just
yeah always hit my head on the right
[Music]
Here I am oh what's that
my full glorious height don't think you
owe you owe you let me crouch all the
way down here barely reach you
with me lost Dave they do need a lift
Hey hello you guys are so normal hided
that must be so sad for you oh you know
you'd make a perfect couple
let's move okay don't worry about that
I'm tall okay okay uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna leave VR now so um so yeah yeah
I'm yeah I will the future of virtual
reality is looking brighter and brighter
by the second there are so many
possibilities and different worlds that
you could explore virtual reality really
opens doors and I am looking forward to
the future that is so bright with
virtual reality in our lives so yeah
thank you everybody so much for watching
look forward to more virtual reality
content coming at you hot and heavy
in the very near future blue do you want
to see down in the comments below and if
you want to see more hey you'll never be
able to know unless you ring that Bell
or subscribe or both so I'm a stable
person I seemed like a good kind of
person to do those things to and far
right you'd wanna know when I was up to
something okay cool alright thank you
again check out more VR stuff that I've
done and
[Music]
I hate myself and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]